honest truth is if she
if she hadn't it's like it's like
i something drove me into pursuing
comedy as hard as i did
yeah i mean and it was two things i
think it was
you know my fear of my future or how i'm
gonna
survive and also heartbreak
you know and those are the two things so
i always
looked at it as i mean obviously i don't
even think about her or
know what she looks i don't care right
but
you're friends yeah i mean i guess
i mean i do like i mean if she if her
and her family came up here
and want to have dinner i guess we would
have dinner but yeah we keep like any
time
she sends you um a christmas card with
her family we put it on yeah yeah yeah
and i appreciate it and um um but
without that heartache i don't think
that i would
of it would have driven me into
you know comedy i mean it was like
depression
and desperation and all those things
um motivated me you know
that's why it's like even now when
things are good
you know i try to find things to um
put me kind of back in that desperation
spot
to motivate me and to get me you know
it's just i don't know if that's healthy
or not but um
you know it's a great motivator for me
you know
fear you know and loss
you know i'm not one of those guys that
like when things go bad
i mean i go i disappear into the night
when things go really bad i fight
and i and i i'm a scrapper
you know i mean i'm a little [ __ ] and
i'm complaining i am become a complainer
and i'm
i'm messy and you know and i know i'm
all those things
as well and all those things that as
well if there's anything
that like there is
you know like we we've been doing this
for so long and there is that i
this idea of you of just being this you
know
kind of chaotic human being kind of just
does what he wants
there is one thing that i wish people
are a side of you that i wish people
knew more of
and that is you are by far the most
tenderest the most tender loving
unabusive person i've ever met
like i grew up in a in a household where
there was always like screaming and
name-calling and anytime there would be
a fight we'd always go for the jugular
that even for me
like when i'm back against the corner i
try to go for like the most
cutting angle um
with him even when he he's not nasty
like that
i'm not nested towards you because i
love you so much i i would never
something about you and my feelings
towards you
and my relationship toward with you um
makes me
not wanna it just it's not i don't wanna
go there
because it's like i love you that much
but you've broken the cycle is what i'm
saying like you grew up
watching i'm no i'm like that with other
people though cutting
yeah i i'm very cutting
i mean you should listen to the [ __ ]
that i say
in warzone to strangers oh yeah but i
say
really crazy [ __ ] i hope you do because
they deserve it
yeah yeah but my point is is that and i
you know i am still that guy
you know but um there are things that
i have in my gun with toward andrew
santino
i do i have a gun and i have three or
four bullets in there that will to
completely
that would completely evaporate our
friendship and our relationship
that was so dark and cutting
right that's gonna make me the champion
of it you know but it'll also destroy
i have that with everyone wow i have
things that i can say
or do right that is going to cut to the
[ __ ] you know root of it
i think we all do though sweetie i know
i know we do right so my point though is
is that
um but with you specifically you know i
mean
i don't do that you know and i've done
that in other relationships where i've
said things right like i remember one
girlfriend i go
i said something i knew it was because
it would be cutting
and very hurtful hold on one second let
me just
looking at your face can i guess what
you said what can i just
guess what you said what did you say
something along the lines of
that's why your dad abandoned you
something like that
yeah yeah how did you guess that i just
saw it in his face
yeah because that's to me that would be
the most painful thing
you could say i've said things like that
right toward a girl
and they'll go thanks a lot
and then cry and turn around and run
away and then when they run away i go
you know like i have that you know
yeah but i'm not like that with her i
would never be like that with her
because
i love her too much it's you know also
it's like um
also you're also f you're you're also
gonna be if i'm gonna go for her jugular
she'll go
right my jugular is exposed
right and i know what she has in her
arsenal
and so you know i'm just going to play i
also i'm going to play you know what i
mean
it's a truce for life you know let me
tell you
she's she's [ __ ] deadly he can
never betray me yeah she knows about me
she knows things about me
right that no one knows so she has me by
the [ __ ] testicles
right and it's like you know i i allowed
that to happen
because i love her so much but she has
you know i mean
she has the information and i i'm [ __ ]
it's a weird say
a weird way of both you saying we're
both vulnerable towards each other
no we're both basically tethered
so tightly to one another yeah like it
we cannot
it won't be an easy break it's gonna be
like
god he has all my secrets he has all of
my secrets
does he know the most secrets out of
anyone in your life no other than your
sister maybe
no he doesn't i those he's dumb he i
know all his secrets he doesn't know
you better get them yeah it's just that
he is somebody who
um like for his thoughts
i i do like this about him he always
needs a place for
his thoughts and ideas like certain
things i keep very
close to my chest so i don't need a
place for them they can stay inside me
i [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up but you know
what um
it's fine i'm i'm fine with it you know
but in terms of like it's it was so
interesting to hear
you know what i mean you didn't get like
in do you ever read the
the mule [ __ ] in the beginning
read the beginning i don't want you to
take it away from me yeah
oh god this is so much
right